you also said George Washington was
viewed about from his slaves like a
father
I guess that's part of what part of the
what the myth I guess is that not all
slave owners were evil some were father
figures like George Washington
there are certain facts that we're not
allowed to talk about like what I would
love to we're doing the taboo yeah we're
mixing it up it's red pill Maybe
[Laughter]
should ban divorce too yeah I think that
should be banned I would say ban divorce
Partners I want you guys to think about
what you're advocating you see your
parents one of your parents should stay
getting beat by the other every day and
you should witness your parents get
their ass beat because they chose to
marry the wrong person that's what y'all
really saying so let me just ask you
generally like what kind of messages are
you sharing on your platform what kind
of important messages is it that you
find yourself are about
um I believe in family so I think that
we should have policies that push family
um I think that feminism overall was a
bad thing I think
um I think women are happier when we
have you know a family and kids over a
career in the long run
um
yeah yeah sorry I'm a little nervous
it's okay yeah you should be you should
be so soft-spoken Ethan started off well
tell us about your reviews as if you
looked at a full page document going
dumb [__] dumb [__] dumb [__] dumb
[__] dumb [__]
page number two dumb [__]
and to be honest you could write a whole
book about how much of it though you
know but anyways it's [__] gonna
obliterate you just because it's easily
you're easily obliterable so it's more
like a traditional you want people to
kind of follow more a more traditional
path
in terms of family and gender and all
that kind of stuff
yeah well and you just see the negative
um like outcomes the society have when
like families fall apart right and it's
especially hard on the children like you
see
you know
um you know more you're more the kids
are more likely to go to listen I know
Rihanna said Diamonds shine bright but
this forehead is glistening and as a
fellow Ethiopian I just want to say
pearl you might be white but that
forehead went on mine you feel me
you know it's just nice to see it on
those big screen so how do you push a
policy that promotes family like in what
way can you
force a family to stay together or
encourage it in a sense
well
well first I have to get rid of inside
like women to leave family
um like you know for example child
support alimony I'm not really a fan of
those okay 90 of divorces don't involve
alimony okay there's no alimony for like
90 of people that is for a select few so
just get that out of the way I think we
should ban divorce too yeah I think that
should be banned I would say ban divorce
so so Banning divorce means that when
you decide to get married you are you
are not allowed by the government to
leave your significant other in any
situation
yeah
that if you want to leave you just
shouldn't get married
if you're saying you're not allowed to
get divorced so we're talking about like
what if the relationship is physically
abusive
I think if it's physically see the
problem though
I did physically abusive okay
fine divorce we can allow divorce for
those exceptions but like I've even
talked to people that work at like abuse
centers and they say that the majority
of abuse is mutual so it's not just one
side's hitting the hitting the other
it's like Mutual so surely that's not
everything I think who cares if it's
mutual why does that even matter if it's
mutual you both of you should be trying
to get a divorce you shouldn't be
together you think like well listen yeah
you know if it's one side they get it
but if it's mutual figure it out excuse
me no if you guys are beating on each
other you might need to just actually
call it quits do you think it's a good
idea to raise a kitten environment with
parents beat on each other regularly and
violence is their first
instinct
why is this even like a rebuttal and the
thing that that in in Trauma Centers
they say that it's mutual they don't
exactly say that it's mutual there's a
Nuance there but what's a Nuance but the
Nuance is that actually the person that
is getting beated up the victim the sort
of say actually has some patterns of
violence as well it doesn't mean that
she's the person that is most physical
or he's the person that is most physical
or whatever but they do engage in that
it's not equal but they do engage in
that that's just a Nuance but Family
Violence was the cause of 25 of divorces
so I don't think it's fair to
characterize that as some kind of like
super Fringe example of why people get
divorced well but you also have to look
if there's incentive structures in place
where there's a lot of false accusations
in Family Court
um like and a lot of people don't know
this that family court is actually based
off it's not based off of evidence it's
based off a balance of probabilities
family core is not based off evidence
it's based off balance of probability
what do you think balance of probability
is based off of
is the burden of proof lower in Family
Court sure doesn't mean that you don't
need evidence you can't just come and
say oh he beats me and have no evidence
you have to document stuff you have to
go to the police you have to have
reports you have to have medical
documentation can't just go to court and
say something happened and then all of a
sudden the courts believe you that's not
the way it works they're going to need
phone records text messages emails why
do you think when people go through
divorces they make such an effort to
keep records of conversations of dates
affidavits witness testimony why because
the bounds of probability is based off
of that evidence you have to show them
she just doesn't know what she's talking
about she's saying things that she's
read online but she doesn't even know
the words she's using and divorce except
for one-sided abuse okay except for
one-sided abuse and is there going to be
a system to kind of uh how do you prove
that that uh the woman or man I think
yeah I think you have to you have to
have press charges in Criminal Court not
family court
so only if your significant other is
tried criminally are you allowed to
leave the relationship tried and found
guilty criminally yes yes
you know what's so funny is like
and they gotta go through a lengthy
lengthy court case that lasts years
before they can finally get divorced
from their partners
during that whole period they have
access to all kinds of things when it
comes to each other just no it comes
down to the fact that
she hasn't experienced much
which is fine
but she thinks she knows a lot
so she goes yeah just do that just do
that like it's it's a just thing like
it's a just do that thing it's not a
just do that thing well yeah if they
just go to court a new Disney like if it
was nothing she all the time that she's
she opens her mouth it's always like
yeah well it's really simple but she
hasn't looked into it or she just
plainly doesn't know and she could she
keeps on saying stuff like that and
here's the thing she's basically telling
people you get your ass beat which I
think like 20 to 25 of all marriage
divorces are actually citing reasons of
abusing them so yeah
when when she says this stuff she's
basically handcuffing people to Dynamics
in which if they don't
take the father of their kids or the
mother of their kids to court and send
them to jail they cannot leave do you
know how many people are gonna have to
stay in relationships because of that do
you know how conflict it must be to
marry somebody to be in love with them
to find out they beat you every day and
now you got to go through the process of
sending them to jail [__] up your
kid's life [__] up your own life
going through the trauma of having to
take someone to court and testify and
sitting that's a lot
but you don't think about all those
minute details when you're going through
this process sometimes it's just better
for the two people to just go their
separate ways not everybody wants to go
through the process of pressing charges
and go through the whole thing and when
you say that they're out is yeah well
then you should remember in the first
the person in the first place like
there's no talking to these people no
there's no logic talking with people
they don't understand that people change
over time like not everybody goes into a
marriage as things are fine then things
don't change afterwards like people
change and just because that thing comes
out later you didn't see at the
foresight doesn't mean you should be
locked into a relationship where you get
beat by your partners I want you guys to
think about what you're advocating you
see your parents one of your parents
should stay again beat by the other
every day and you should witness your
parents get their ass beat because
they've chose to marry the wrong person
that's what y'all really saying y'all
really to let your moms or your dads get
beat up by their partnership abuse and
potentially even die one day because a
lot of this stuff does lead to death
right because they chose the wrong
person if you guys really can look at
your parents and say they should stay
through that kind of situation kudos to
you I could never I would tell my mom to
get a hundred divorces before she even
took one single punch to the face y'all
would condemn somebody for life to that
y'all built different than me no no man
tough it out y'all build different than
me tell your mama took it out yeah she
can work too the only people who I know
would say this kind of goofy [__] are
dudes who probably have the plans of
beating their Partners to be honest with
you or people that haven't like MLT who
be beating women that's the only people
I say or goofy women who want to make
money off goofy red pill people but I
was quoting a Thomas Sowell book
[Music]
so
yeah okay
who's that yeah so Thomas Sowell is an
author who talks about the history of
slavery
so yes so also but do you so do you
agree with that premise that slavery was
embellished or no
um I think that
there are parts that are under
embellished and there are parts that are
over embellished I think it just depends
what we're talking so interesting I've
got to know what was over embellished
about slavery
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I know what white people can't say no
say it
you've activated my trap Clark how
excited he is tell me what you don't
like about blacks
just like one example I'm dying to know
[Music]
yeah I just I just rather I mean I was
talking about a book that I read and I
think to understand the context you'd
have to read the book you just said some
parts were embellished some parts were
under the embellished I I just think are
you retracting that
I just I
I'd really just rather not
but okay
he knows what he's doing
he said cross it [__] why you why are
you stuttering he said it's over
embellished go ahead go ahead cross it
and
man the things we are willing to do for
positions but not ourselves eh you
should do the same thing take care of
your possession take care of your skin
yeah because right now I'm using this
brush to get in the nooks and crannies
on my bike to get all the dirt and grime
out you should do that with your skin
with your face thinly has a cream for
that exfoliating cream it gets in the
pores of your skin and clean it out yeah
and after that
use daily facial wash and when I'm done
washing my bike what I'm going to do is
I'm going to apply a special wax that's
going to protect it from the sun rays
you should do that to your skin morning
facial moisturizer with SPF 20. that's
for the sun rays
take care of your stuff take care of
your face click on the link below and
you're going to be able to get 30 off
your first box and not only that they're
going to send you free gifts
so while I do this you do that click on
the link below get yourself set to have
a better skin
people judge you in your possession
people judge you on your skin get it now
I'll be right here cleaning
gone
ah
you know what slavery being embellished
that's so interesting I don't know how
you embellish it there are certain facts
that we're not allowed to talk about
like what I would love to we're doing a
taboo yeah we're mixing it up it's red
pill baby
[Laughter]
topics I I just I genuinely want to know
how it was embellished yeah yeah what
can't we talk about come on
I mean I could show you
come on cancel yourself come on do it
rather not get into this so
sounds like a blue pilled attitude of me
this [__] yeah
um I just again I was kind of hoping
this was like a good faith interview
wait what's that faith I'm literally
showing you clips of you saying stuff
yeah I just I'm yeah wait hold on I'm
sorry I'm sorry what about this
interview has been bad faith
I just think you're kind of trying to
push an agenda and you're not
I just think you're trying to that's a
clip of you saying that because I was
talking about how the founder of the guy
the Thomas Sowell talks about how the
guy that made root talked about how it
was a myth for his people to live by
okay that's what the guy who made root
set Alex Haley okay
so and I can't even talk about that on a
podcast without being canceled by the
internet yeah but mythology okay just
because the story that he told himself
with the movie of roots isn't real does
not mean the things depicted in there
didn't happen that doesn't mean that
that was embellished okay the reality of
slavery was Far darker than the roots
movie could have ever shown that's just
a fact just because he's mythology is
like a culture and history that doesn't
mean the way it's depicted in the movie
was how it actually happened
and that's that's what he was talking
about on the book but again I was
quoting a book and you're trying to like
pin me down on quoting a book
let me Swatch this again and see if I'm
doing that free stuff too because that's
that's literally they they the founder
of or the guy who made Roots for my
people to live by so they often but
that's what they do then you say but
here's what they do and I'm not trying
to say it wasn't horrible I'm not gonna
say it wasn't horrible it's right but
they want to make it like more horrible
they want to make it more for that they
can control people so that they can
control people right but if I disagrees
I mean she brought him off she gotta eat
that let's keep watching wait oh my gosh
five minutes before I say solo talks
about this in his book
so I'm communicating in the interview
that I'm quoting an author you're not
being honest
you say I they do this to okay so you
disavowed just disavow it then that's
easy just say I don't think slavery was
embellished I mean that's super easy
that's like a layup
do you agree you know what I mean it's
like just say you don't think slavery
was embellished I think there are
certain facts that you're not allowed to
talk about I don't really want to talk
about it oh I'm just asking you do you
agree with that statement
Barack Obama is comparable to Adolf
Hitler
all right
no okay
see it's my heart it's not hard that's
awesome that's easy to do
for the class
they put the glass
if he's clapping her right now she's
getting claps you also said George
Washington was viewed about from his
slaves like a father
I guess that's part of what the the
or the what the myth I guess is that not
all slave owners were evil some were
father figures like George Washington
oh
yeah
this editing is crazy yeah this ending
is crazy
I just have to think Pearl's got to be
one of the dumbest [__] people on the
planet to go on the HD podcast and think
this [__] was not gonna come up did you
say that
I don't remember I think like if
someone's a great and powerful man in
history to the point like they're
talking about him hundreds of years
later he didn't have any kids but he did
the own slaves what to be on slaves
Jules Washington yeah he did yeah not
real men to me I'm just saying he
actually it's actually interesting he um
he had a different like he inherited his
slaves and it wasn't as simple as he
could have just like let them go because
um the debt that's incurred on them like
you can't just release them and so he
his slave's actually like he had a
really good relationship with them and
they considered him like a dad
what's your source for that
was from a Thomas Sowell book
Thomas Soul so he's your guy Thomas
Souls the man there was a time where I
started to read accounts from actual
slaves so these were like in like the
and you know I can't really talk about
this like even if I talk about this now
they're gonna clip it they're gonna say
things I didn't I didn't say but it's
like I used to
read actual slave accounts and I was
surprised how many didn't say bad things
about their owners after they were free
play the thing just
played it play the thing you guys you
guys never heard of Stockholm syndrome
played a thing you know people who are
held captive start developing a very
sympathetic empathetic relationship with
their Captor
because of the trauma that's inflicted
upon them mentally this girl's really
trying to sit here and say like yo a lot
of slaves actually love their masters
because in a really [__] up
psychological way they had to learn to
to be able to endure to be with some rod
you know the thing that you want to do
for beat up women in their relationship
endure
all right do you know how many people
feel the same way about The Men Who
groomed them when they were underaged do
you think children just because the fact
that when they got free from their pedo
captors still had a sympathetic bond
that made that relationship okay or any
less worse what if a 10 year old falls
in love with an adult grapes them all
the time it says good things about them
that we shouldn't see the adult as evil
as anybody else
sometimes when I hear these people speak
I think they just hear whatever
information confirms what they want to
believe and then they just go with it
what are you talking about
oh he was a good slave master
okay
and it's not to say like slavery was a
horrible institution but I can't talk
about that fact without getting canceled
I can't say hey these slaves had a good
relationship with their owners it's not
true because it's just not true it's not
true what George Washington was not a
father figure to his slaves well if you
Rick look up like um I think it was book
47 let's see 47 of George Washington's
slaves tried to escape
would you try to escape maybe that maybe
that one was wrong I I don't I don't
know this was like okay
a little bit on a podcast months ago I
don't really remember but and and I said
I wasn't sure if it was Washington
either in that interview
at some point but George Washington was
bringing up as I'm not even allowed to
have this conversation without what do
you mean that but I mean we're issues
not that you can't have this
conversation it's just that because it's
such a sensitive topic you have no idea
how to cut through it efficiently you're
just going at it with a [__] paddle
and you're wondering why the meat coming
out all crazy and you're trying to serve
it to people and people will be like um
uh I didn't ask for a smashed raw Burger
yeah people are gonna have an issue
they're gonna complain if you want to
take on the typical stuff that's fine do
your due diligence when you were on that
[__] podcast with Nick you didn't do
your due diligence you just let some
White Russians come up there and ramble
for talk for a while about how black
people are inferior and how slavery
isn't a big deal that's your problem if
I'm gonna tackle a big soft chick like
that like in a serious tone you best
believe I'm gonna do it properly there's
been plenty of times people like I have
a talk about Palestine I don't know [__]
about it so I ain't gonna jump on it and
I would be I wouldn't be surprised
if I'm like hey man Palestinians this or
that and folks got mad
no either sides are going to put people
on no matter whatever it is why because
I don't know what I'm talking about
exactly let's go away I can't even you
can discuss anything do it in private if
you want to do it in public and you want
to give spicy takes about how slavery
was embellished [__] you better have
your receipts and if people ask you
better stand on 10 on that I just wanted
to know what your thoughts are on this
that's all
um yeah I'm not like my channel isn't
about slavery if it's not then why'd you
bring on the Juventus why would you
bring on somebody who's a non-wise
precious if your Channel's not about
that that's your problem stupid it's
like I can't say my thing is not a
political Channel then I bring on
[__] Joe Biden and then he starts
rattling off about Democratic policy
marriage is supposed to be you know for
better for worse and sickness and in
health and that's a part of the vowel
that's a part of The Vow I've been to
enough marriages not for their marriages
none for them marriages and you always
choose to take that vow that side of the
vow that part of The Vow what about the
part of The Vow uh where we talk about
mutual respect
what about the part of The Vow were you
talking about you're supposed to protect
each other
what about the part of The Vow are you
supposed to be become one no you Chuck
all that [__] out the window and then
you choose the one that you're like hey
better or worse this is the worst to fit
out that's not what the vowel is
they don't go to they don't go to church
and be like all right
uh
uh For Better or Worse for better words
for better words on three one two three
better or worse and then they get
married that's not what happens and the
majority of divorces nowadays it's just
you know when the girl just feels like
leaving that's not true and and well
yeah it's just not true I've talked to
I've talked to hundreds of women the uh
abuse of power and the risk for abuse
and for people to get stuck in a
horrible relationship situation not just
for them but their kids right I mean
obviously we have seeing having your
kids watch their mother get beat up and
and oftentimes it's going to bleed or
the kids get watching their father get
beat up like it goes both ways I've yeah
and I acknowledge that it goes both ways
so both people have a right to
in my opinion get divorced because the
alternative is one of the partners being
stuck and like do you do you think it's
actually a lethal uh do you think that's
the majority of cases a majority of
cases of what divorce I'm divorced 25
25 it's 25 based on statistics that's
not no that's not what's um in criminal
court it's like less than less than 10
um it actually followed through in
Criminal Court well regardless 10 is
enough don't you think no I said less
than 10 of the abuse cases of the 25
that's like
Journal of Family Violence in 2014
founded approximately 25 of divorces in
the United States involved domestic
violence
right but again that's because the woman
says that she was because they're inside
but you're just saying stuff you're just
saying stuff you don't actually know
that to be true no I do oh I do like
okay in the UK there's a law that you
get a free lawyer if um
how does that prove that women are lying
about violence because no because I'm
saying that you can't okay you can't
prove it unless they go to criminal
court because Criminal Court is based
off of evidence where where family court
is based off of a balance of
probabilities which is also evidence you
can't just say your partner beats you
without evidence he's just saying the
same [__] this girl's [__] stupid
this girl's really incredibly dumb you
can't go to Farley Family Court say your
partner beats you and then they just
leave that's not how it works they have
to have some evidence she's not dumb she
has three cassettes and she's just
playing the same one she played before
yo it goes in reverse like she doesn't
know what she's talking about she just
rewind that [__] and played it back
that's that you can't prove it unless
you go to criminal court because family
is not a crime right but they're not
going to jail it's just about the
welfare of the kids and you know I mean
the people it's a crime if you're if
you're falsely accusing someone of abuse
um I'm saying I'm saying there's no you
can't they only prove it in less than 10
of cases okay because Criminal Court is
based off of evidence family court is
not she just keeps saying that amen
when dads win cases to get cussing their
children they're doing it based off
evidence they have to Showcase evidence
that the mother is sick or whatever the
same could be said the other way around
they're saying the dad father's a
deadbeat they gotta show he didn't pay
his payments they got to show written
receipts like this is just stupid so
let's just say less than 10 I'll just
give you the benefit of the doubt on
that still seems like enough
to give people the option to leave and
this idea that women just leave whenever
they want seems a little bit infantile
since because people change right
especially when people get married young
which does happen people change people
uh go through [__] people grow apart
it's like almost even been watching our
video shout outs to you brother you're
in the right arguments and let's see
what happens
congratulations so you're researchers uh
you're plagiarizing but it's okay
I'm just playing you didn't come up with
this original thought other people have
said it too I'm just saying we the ones
who might have said on YouTube recently
you'll get super hurt about just hanging
okay just lonely things we just want to
talk about it
give us some credit make sure all right
you references do you think King she
just look like an idiot on most topics
as she normally does
uh
the minute you win on Ethan decline you
look like a
yeah it was done it was done
I really thought this interview was
about it but I've got high
of course not I mean it wasn't a bad
faith interview that was not a bad face
interview but what do you think Ethan
was about to do make you shine bright
like a diet
nah you're not gonna sound right like a
diamond you got the forehead of Rihanna
but it's not gonna happen
okay he's not gonna do that he's gonna
be like man he's gonna do he's gonna do
what Ethan does and on top of that he's
been [__] on the red pill Community
you wanted them he gonna [__] on you too
true it's like I'm not saying it's a bad
faith interview but come on what
happened there that's what well that's
what was supposed to happen well I
really thought that this
[__] you me
well that's it anything else you want to
say about just lonely things
stay lonely
apparently this girl about hit 27 she's
about to hit that break off age where
her value plummets off a cliff
technically she already asked
they say 25 often true so I think she
said 27 to give herself some time maybe
yeah she's like damn about 26 I can't be
saying 25. I gotta round it off I think
in one year I could find a man I think
like in six months you're gonna say
third are you homeless I'm a high value
woman I think we're a good fit
good luck anything else you want to say
please